access
wow
where are the crab cakes
oh that's there underneath there are
they mini crab cakes are we uh the chef
has decided that those are the size that
he needs to serve
i mean that tastes dreadful that thing
tastes sort of washy and soapy
and twenty dollars for them
he's as cheap with his crab cakes as he
is with his staff
now for the lamb with robert's
ridiculous 15 extra charge
it's um a rack of lamb encrusted in
macadamia nuts uh fresh herbs and a
little bit of dijon mustard it's served
with a honey vinegar reduction
it's not even cooked properly
rested and take that off
i always get nervous when you see white
fat like that
on the side of the chop
[Music]
is it to your liking
i mean
it's pretty raw in the center you like
the flavor of it though the honey garden
no way too sweet
i i'm i'm not satisfied with uh the
quality of the foods coming out of the
kitchen i believe our chef has a
learning curve to be where he needs to
be thank you
we just lost our other chef
why did the chef leave
i'm supposed to tell you the truth right
the truth is all i want to know
why did the chef leave
well her paycheck
she put all her everything on her uh
charge cuts and and she just figured she
wasn't paid back for what she was chef
bought produce she did she did
everything she was the best chef ever
wow that's dreadful
i'm starving um the peanut butter
chocolate decadence uh i could do with
some of that pick me up please
thank you
god a chef that left because you had to
buy produce on her own credit card i
mean this guy's priorities are upside
down
a bit like this in
okay are you ready
this he said
he doesn't care for the sweetness
there's fat around it he didn't care for
the flavor of the honeyguard
[Music]
wow thank you very much did you cut it
in half because it looks like someone's
taking it and where's the other half
gone uh it goes to the another person
who orders i know i want my to have
seventy four dollars
this place is insane
listen half my dessert's missing if you
think i'm spending seventy four dollars
for a dessert
that
is half cocked
[Music]
it's actually quite nice
there is hope i'm sorry
i'm going to say that that is not a
dessert that he made
bama made it no somebody else makes
desserts it's ordered like store-bought
like through one of our purveyors
what
where's the chef he's in the kitchen can
you get him out please yes
what how you doing chef julian in my
opinion is not living up to his
potential as a chef he will try to cut
corners and i think gordon needs to know
these things i've just spent 74 for
three plates of absolute dire dated [ __ ]
food
[Music]
crab cakes yes sir you can't put two
little half testicle-sized [ __ ] crab
cakes that came from a can there's
bigger [ __ ] cakes chef at the [ __ ]
canopy party my lamb was cold in the
middle the fat was white it was like a
mouthful of sugar the best tasting dish
for me was the [ __ ]
chocolate peanut thing that i got served
half a portion that's not even made
[ __ ] in-house
what is this there's no synergy here
there is honestly a lack of
communication often sometimes when i'm
in the middle of doing breakfast service
for the 10 people that we randomly get i
get five texts from him asking me a
question
why are you texting him if you have a
question maybe leave the rv and come out
and talk to him show me those texts are
you nitpicking are you trying to control
him are you no i'm trying to make sure i
i'm i haven't been sleeping very well to
be honest with you and uh i've had i've
been beaten down
i'll take responsibility for everything
that happens in the kitchen you don't
own the place you own it yeah he's
acting more responsible
what do you earn a week if you don't
mind me asking a thousand dollars before
taxes 400.
jesus christ almighty
400 a week to be the head chef in a
luxury hotel that's insane i mean you're
barely surviving i'm i'm i don't know
that i'm even barely surviving if you're
not happy with your work environment you
should leave are you taking the piss or
is this just an abuse for you
what are you doing to these people
so they're livelihoods this is your
responsibility
[Music]
rob's world
and you're in an rv a hundred grand
everybody is disgusted that you live in
that thing they really are
because it costs so much money and they
can't get their paycheck on time
well that is not the that is part of the
issue we are surrounded by wealth and
reminded of poverty at the same time
because of that rv it's a symbol to me
that rv is a symbol
and it's a symbol that you're separating
yourself from everybody else i'd be very
careful about coming down on me too hard
[Music]
i'm telling you exactly how i feel and
how that makes the people that i work
with feel let me tell you how i feel
when you're in your [ __ ] kitchen all
day long and you're on the goddamn
internet instead of actually trying to
perfect a menu and get a menu how long
did i ask for you to make a menu of your
own if i'm on the computer usually as
i'm trying to research menus research
ingredients give me a break i've given
you plenty of breaks i work very long
days yeah and i haven't been paid in
three weeks there's only been one
paycheck that i got on time almost the
entire staff is ready to walk out
because they are tired of not getting
paid
anything to say
[Music]
no we do things oh please
[Music]
you